if you were to look at the american
nation the american empire
and the trajectories looking into the
future given these measures
what is the trajectory that leads to the
collapse of the american empire based on
these measures what are the concerning
indicators and if
um if those break down further what does
that look like
well
all of those indicators
are concerning
maybe
except for one which is technology
the technology niche
although even in that area the united
states is
improving at a slower rate than is china
for various advantages that they have
there they put out about eight times as
many computer engineers their free data
and so on
but if you look at them
so the financial is a is a concern
the
internal order disorder is a concern
then if you look at education levels the
united states
is in many way is is losing its
educational advantage
if you were to look at compare it with
china
if you take general public education in
the united states
it's deteriorated
tremendously even in comparison to
developed countries there are scores
pisa scores and so on and it's you know
something like 38th in the world or
something and that was a big plunge
average public education
if you look at the best universities in
the world the united states is unique in
having the best universities in the
world so there are these privileged
spots
um that are you know excellent
um uniquely excellent so when you look
at the comparison education in china
is improving rapidly
and it and the quantity
is a quantity of educated people in the
areas that they're moving in are is is
greater
and the resources that they're putting
behind it is greater and so you see the
results are greater
but
it's sort of along the lines that i'm
i'm dealing with if you were to follow
through
in terms of um
actual productions i i think you you
know in terms of technologies um there
are some areas that the united states is
in a lead at the moment there's some
areas that china's in a lead but china
is great gaining
very quickly when i first went to china
1984
i would bring ten dollar calculators and
i gave them away as gifts to
high-ranking people and they thought
they were miracle devices
right now in terms of areas like quantum
computing and a.i and and
you know many areas um you have a race
going on and so if you take the
trajectory of the competitiveness not
just look at the current level you have
a situation where they're improving at a
much faster rate this is all good for
the world if the world can get along
and the main thing i think is
[Music]
in just
how do you have a healthy world and how
do you have a strong economy and how do
you have a strong situation
is be strong
the united states is war is with itself
that's the main war you know it's very
simple in history
um
[Music]
be financially sound
earn more than you spend
um
and be strong in these ways
and pretty much everything will take
care of itself
but you make it sound simple of course
because there's a momentum when things
degrade when the education system
degrades when you start borrowing
when
i mean all of these indicators once once
they start going down it's uh there's a
momentum to it right so it's hard to
reverse it right and there are
circumstances that you're then in
uh for example
indebtedness
you know it's politically
desirable for those in
to borrow money and spend
because their constituencies only look
at what they get
and when they get a lot they don't pay
attention to the balance sheet and how
much debt is on the books so it's always
better to
borrow spend and then leave the cleanup
to the next guy
and so you inherit a lot
you inherited as
a new president enters in or new
legislators they have a lot of debt they
have a broken down infrastructure
they don't have enough money to fix that
and so that's the lay of the land that
the prior generations
put you in
and there you are and so that's right
it's difficult because when you start to
think okay what's healthy well spend
earn more than you spend well that's not
so easy
because you know what does that mean go
earn more i mean okay that's not so easy
spend less that isn't going to work
so now what do you do okay you have this
debt that you then monetize
and that's why it's classic so yes
that's why these cycles occur because
what has created before put
what happened before created the lay of
the land that is then increasingly
difficult to deal with
so what can great leaders do in this
moment i mean maybe uh
my sense is leadership is crucial here
so for example to do very large projects
that invest in the education system that
sort of try to
fix the fundamentals or maybe
invest more and more into the innovation
and the development of new technologies
and so on
it feels like that just doesn't happen
organically
so you have to have strong
leaders that
convince the populace of the importance
of these ideas
well i completely agree with your list
what we have is a situation where
everybody
has their opinions and they have to sort
of get them exactly right and they all
fight with each other about whether
their opinions so the most important
thing
is that we are become bipartisan so that
we don't
and we get over our differences i would
have a bipartisan cabinet
i would draw upon
both members of both parties the the
moderates who are going to be able to
work together
so as then we have one country
and then we deal with those in
a means that works for the majority of
the people in the middle rather than the
polarity i think our greatest risk is in
not being able to do that so i would say
that's
a paramount importance
because we have the resources you know
um
wealth real wealth and
science and everything has never been
better than it is
but the notion is that it has to work
for the majority of people
and we
have to keep it being productive
so that that group has got to calmly and
knowledgeably work together so that they
increase the size of the pie and they
create broad-based prosperity so that is
a paramount importance
whatever they do if they do it that way
i can say i'm happy about because that
other alternative is the really scary
alternative
you